Kasparov played Rook captures on D4 and
topalo accepted the challenge look at
this Rook to E7 check you cannot capture
The Rook otherwise you get a very nasty
Checkmate here with the queen and Knight
so the King has to start running Queen
captures King captures Pawn to B4 King
A4 and queen to C3 threatening Checkmate
so toal of stops it but now Rook A7
threatening Checkmate on A6 Bishop to B7
you capture and you cannot capture back
due to the exact same Checkmate so Queen
C4 now Queen captures on F6 threatening
Checkmate here and the King has to start
running Queen captures King captures and
now of course Pawn to C3 check the final
nail in the coffin Queen A1 check King
to D2 Queen B2 check King to D1 and
Bishop to F1 uh Rook to D2 but of course
the deflection Rook to D7 Rook captures
and now Bishop captures on C4 and the
point of it all is that the Rook on h8
is hanging this is kasparov's Immortal
the full game is available on my channel
do check it out hope you enjoyed it see
you soon